now it is time to put on my Stephen
Colbert smart glasses and give the final
thought for today's final thought I'm
going to do the unthinkable I am going
to defend Hollywood the horror the
horror specifically I'm going to defend
Darren Aronofsky's movie mother starring
Jennifer Lawrence which I just saw
yesterday I think I am the only
conservative in the country who enjoyed
mother right wingers have been excreting
this film a writer a National Review
called it the vilest film Hollywood has
ever produced and the great John Nolte
even said that it's an environmentalist
anti-christian anti human screed now
with respect to my friends in the
conservative movement conservatives are
Philistines and they have missed the
rich narrative of this movie now
Jennifer Lawrence and Aronofsky himself
might misunderstand it too artists often
get their own work wrong but the movie
doesn't really make sense if Lawrence's
character is seen as Mother Earth it
makes much more sense if we realize that
Jennifer Lawrence's character is Satan
it is a mill Tony analogous for
Christianity much like Paradise Lost now
the movie is difficult to watch
particularly its depiction of mankind
and the Blessed Sacrament but that's the
point the movie is told from the point
of view of Jennifer Lawrence who is
Satan a mother is a theological a
serious movie that presents a thorough
and disconcerting portrait of the
insidiousness of sin and the
unfathomable magnitude of God's love and
inventiveness we have a sympathetic
Satan character here just like we do in
Paradise Lost and Mother's sympathy
Jennifer Lawrence's characters sympathy
for the devil should startle Christian
audiences out of these sentimental
complacency and shallowness that
Aronofsky assails in his humans it's
worth a watch you should go see yeah
that's our show I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Noel's show come back
tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
[Music]